no that is the kind of paradox right now
we've got a 1.4 trillion dollar now
student loan crisis and I talk to young
lady the other day from here on the air
from South Carolina and she wanted to go
to Mississippi and going to go to Ole
Miss and which involves out-of-state
tuition which triples her cost of
college and I said so why is it you want
to go to Ole Miss it's a pretty town see
it's scary to me how the paradox is that
the oxymoron is is that were fools about
education we're idiots when it comes to
education and that kind of oxymoron it
it seem like you got to be like smart
about education and in this case it's
really wise is what it amounts to and so
what's happened is is that so many
people have been completely overwhelmed
with their student loan debt that now
there's this whole movement out there
that says oh no education is worth it
it's not worth it don't go to college
it's ridiculous to go to college college
is ridiculous you shouldn't go to
college and that's an overreaction
that's just as dumb as go anywhere you
want because it's all gonna work out
okay both of those are done hey listen I
believe in education
I know stuff that I wouldn't have known
if I didn't go to class hello
you know and that makes my life move
along at a better pace I can actually
look at an accounting spreadsheet and I
know what it means because I had you
know eight quarters of accounting and
getting my finance degree so I actually
having knowledge base that allows me to
run a two hundred million dollar
business I couldn't do that with a high
school diploma I could do it but it
would be a lot more of a strain because
I wouldn't know how and knowing how to
do stuff is what knowledge is you know
and so that's what you guys want to look
for and look I appreciate the question a
lot but moms and dads when you've got a
looka in your life it's asking these
questions and obviously he's had some
good coaching because he's already going
I'm going to California Community
College is free I'm going first two
years there and then Longford you get my
basics out of the way that'll all
transfer and no one
ask you even if they do ask you where
you graduate from school they didn't ask
you where you went first
there's ask you where you graduated from
and that's the three people in your life
that'll ever ask you reason only time
compass um I ask you where you want the
schools they want to know what football
team you root for I mean that's the only
reason they care where you went to
school where'd you go to school oh
you're a vol huh yeah go Vols so so
we're my little orange tee around right
and people go you know but they don't go
like oh wow that was academically
imperiling you know it's not you were
not imperil at UT with your academics it
was but solid I mean it's all obviously
and so folks really do take the time to
think about education there's only one
time you can look at education it's just
generally life enhancing and that's just
that's if you have an unbelievably
luxurious budget and you can just go
study for the sake of study oh that's
neat and justum you know I didn't
broaden my horizons and that's true but
you really have to in our world that I
look at it from a utilitarian standpoint
which does bring some of you into trade
school and there's no shame in that at
all I mean a good aircraft mechanic a
good be so mechanic make 100k and a
whole bunch of you with master's degree
in sociology making 28 grand okay so I
mean think about what you're doing here
the trade school there is no shame in
that game whatsoever none at all
but think about what it is you're gonna
get for what you pay and is this in your
budget am i getting quality for what I'm
paying when you go out of state you are
not paying for an increased value you're
paying for geography which when it comes
to education would be known as stupid
unless you have that extra money and you
just want to take you a little adventure
to Mississippi you know if you want to
take a little adventure to Mississippi
cuz the town's pretty just make sure you
have the money don't make a make
yourself the 30 year old version of you
hate the 20 year old version
because when you're 30 and you're still
paying those student loan debt you're
going those houses in Mississippi are
not that petty that's what you'll be
thinking it changes everything
moms and dads teaching kids be sure your
parenting 18 year olds they can still
need parents when they're 18 they still
need somebody love them and say no
that's dumb that's dumb
don't be dumb really when it comes to
education don't be dumb it's kind of
oxymoronic if you think it through this
is the Dave Ramsey show